thomas bonjour qu'en est il de la
situation sur place est ce que les
manifestants ont répondu présents à
cette manifestation pourtant interdite
par les autorités
ça c'est difficile de vous répondre en
réalité puisqu'il n'ya pas de cortège à
proprement parler il ya des petits
groupes qui ont tenté de se réunir on
est dans le quartier depuis plus de deux
heures maintenant et on voit des
personnes essayer de se rassembler mais
il ya une présence des forces de l'ordre
absolument énorme beaucoup beaucoup de
crs et de gendarmes qui sont déployés
depuis au moins deux heures maintenant
ici à dans le quartier barbès on
exactement boulevard de barbès au fond
de la rue il ya un escadron de crs qui
est en train d'avancer qui a utilisé
tout à l'heure le canon à eau pour
disperser des rassemblements de
manifestants et on voit des personnes
autour de nous qui viennent nous
demander est ce qu'il ya une
manifestation aujourd'hui alors on est
en bien ou en mal pour leur répondre
puisque vous l'avez dit cette
manifestation a été interdite et les
organisateurs eux appellent toujours à
manifester d'ailleurs ils ont tenu une
conférence de presse tout à l'heure et
on a assisté à cette conférence de
presse je propose d'écouter quelques-uns
des extraits que nous avons recueillies
donc parmi les organisateurs cette
manifestation
on regrette les propos du ministre de
l'intérieur et on condamne ces propos
qui a manifestement déclaré que cette
manifestation était une manifestation
antisémite
donc cet amalgame et ces accusations
sont pour nous intolérable et ne peuvent
pas nous faire taire terre la solidarité
avec le peuple palestinien
leurs fuseaux aussi ce sont les
déclarations de d'emmanuel macron
président de la république qui affiche
est depuis le début sur sa solidarité
totale avec l'état d'israël en
condamnant les attaques terroristes
de dieu hamas et d autre organisation
qualifiée de terroriste et qui n'a eu
aucun mot pour condamner ce qui se passe
tous les jours on palestine occupée
le résultat c'est qu'il y a déjà eu des
erreurs ici dans le quartier de barbès
on a vu plusieurs fois le canon à eau
entrer en action on a vu aussi des
charges policières contre des groupes de
manifestants la stratégie
vraisemblablement c'est d'empêcher tout
toute formation d'un cortège toute
formation d'un groupe et c'est dans un
certain nombre de personnes alors dès
qu'il ya du monde qui sait se rassembler
ici plusieurs dizaines de personnes
parfois des passants qui essaient de se
mêler à la foule c'est très compliqué
pour les forces de l'ordre de 2 d'agir
et donc il y à des charges policières
assez régulière et surtout vous allez le
voir sur ces images une présence de
forces de l'ordre avec un nombre très
impressionnant de camions qui est
déployé dans le quartier que ce soit
donc de la gendarmerie ou des crs
oh